Today we examine the requirement of good faith by examining the case of market
street associates versus fry.
The implied covenant of Good Faith and fair dealing is a mandatory rule that
parties will deal with each other in good faith.
It's an implied obligation in every contract,
meaning it does not need to be explicitly written or stated and it can't be
disclaimed.
The covenant is incorporated into the uniform commercial code section one dash
three Oh four and section two dash one oh three defines good faith in the case
of merchants as honesty in fact and the observance of reasonable commercial
standards of fair dealing in the trade.
The restatement Second Section Two oh five also states that every contract
imposes upon each party a duty of good faith and fair dealing in its performance
and its enforcement.
The case of market street associates versus fry was decided by the seventh
circuit in 1991 the opinions author,
Judge Richard Posner is a leading figure in the field of law and economics.
The Journal of Legal Studies identified him as the most cited legal scholar of
the 20th century.
He is the closest thing we have today to Oliver Wendell Holmes,
a Promethian scholar turn judge with seemingly unbounded capacities.
The opinion while very long gives a detailed explanation of judge Posner's take
on the duty of good faith in contracts,
JC penny and General Electric Pension Trust entered into a sale and leaseback
agreement to understand the case.
It's useful to understand that sale and leaseback transactions are incredibly
similar to a mortgage loan but are characterized as sale and lease back for
various tax purposes with alone.
Of course,
the lender initially lends money to a borrower and the borrower then pays back
the loan with smaller periodic payments
with a sale and leaseback transactions.
The cashflows are identical.
The effective lender in this case,
General Electric Pension Trust initially sends the cuase I borrower JC Penney,
a bunch of money when GE buys the property and then Jacques Pinay effectively
pays back the loan when it sends a it's periodic rent money back to the lender
at the end of the lease back period.
That cuase I bar often can repurchase the property by paying what is similar to
what would be a balloon payment.
If the transaction where a traditional mortgage loan.
Of course if this had been a traditional business loan,
JC penny would have been able to make improvements and uh,
and it's property and parties to sale and leaseback transactions often include
provisions to give the renter this affective borrower various rights to allow
the same kinds of improvement in the property without distorting the parties.
Incentives regarding the buyback option.
In this case,
the contract included a provision requiring the trust to give reasonable
consideration and to negotiate in good faith.
Should JC penny make request to borrow more money for improvements to the leased
property,
the contract further stated that should negotiations fail this,
the negotiations to acquire this new funding a JC Penney would be entitled to
immediately buy back the property from the trust with the purchase price
stipulated by a formula specified in the contract.
These important provisions are in paragraph 34 of the lease.
Even though the contractual formula was an attempt to capture what the value of
the property would be in the future,
the formula in this case failed to accurately reflect what the market price
turned out to be.
So at the time of this dispute,
the formula price was far below the actual market price of the property.
JC Penny later assigned its interest in the lease a two market street which was
the plaintiff and that now the appellant market street requested financing from
the trust without informing the trust about the contractual terms granting
market street and option to buy the property immediately at the formulaic price
should the financing negotiations fail.
The trust,
uh,
was apparently unaware of the purchase option term in the contract.
The negotiations failed and market street attempted to exercise the purchase
option at the formulaic price stipulated in the contract which has mentioned
above was well below the market value after the trust refused to sell the
property at that price market street sued for specific performance.
The district court granted summary Judgment to the trust ruling that market
street's behavior violated a good faith contractual requirement in the instant
decision.
Judge Posner writing for the appellate panel reversed and remanded holding that
the facts could be construed to find that market straight behaved in good faith.
Just to make sure we understand the facts of the case.
What does paragraph 34 of the lease and title the lessee to do?
Which term did market street fail to disclose about?
Two important things.
First,
it allows market street to request that the pension trust finance,
the cost and expense of improving on the property.
The pension fund is under a contractual obligation to consider and negotiate in
good faith after it receives this request.
Second,
if these negotiation fails,
the contract gives market street the option to immediately repurchase the
property at a price derived from a formula specified in the contract.
Market Street's alleged failure was one of nondisclosure.
They did not inform the trust about the purchase option term in paragraph 34
which gave market street this right or option to repurchase the property.
Should negotiations fail like judge suitor in Central Phoenix?
Judge Posner emphasizes that good faith can mean different things at different
stages of contracting.
At the formation stage,
the duty is minimized whereas at the performance and post contractual
enforcement stage and good faith is heightened because of change circumstances
and the parties were reliance.
Judge Posner says,
quote,
before the contract is signed,
the parties confront each other with a natural wariness.
Neither expects the other to be particularly forthcoming and therefore there's
no deception when one is not afterward,
the situation is different.
The parties are now in a cooperative relationship.
The cost of which will be considerably reduced by a measure of trust.
So each lowers his guard a bit and now silence is more apt to be deceptive.
Posner sees that,
uh,
the good faith duty is equivalent to the law finding and implied or our default
condition to a contract and suggests that the goal of courts in setting these
implied conditions should be quote to give the parties what they would have
stipulated for expressly if at the time of making the contract they had had
complete knowledge of the future and the cost of negotiating and adding
provisions to the contract had been zero.
He says that the concept of the duty of good faith,
like the concept of fiduciary duty is a stab at approximating the terms the
parties would have negotiated had they foreseen the circumstances that have
given rise to their dispute.
These petitions are classic statements of what contract theorists call
hypothetical default setting,
setting the legal default at what the parties would have wanted.
So what would the parties have wanted?
Posner suggest that the duty of good faith in this context is quote halfway
between a fiduciary duty,
the duty of utmost good faith and the duty merely to refrain from active fraud.
Despite its moralistic overtones.
It's no more the injection of moral principles into contract law than the
fiduciary concept itself is unquote.
The major issue is whether market street's duty of good faith to the trust
included a duty to disclose the repurchase consequence.
The courts ruled yes,
judge Posner reason that both market street and the trust might want to minimize
the cost of performing the contract.
The point of the doctrine of good faith is to reduce defensive expenditures.
So at least in part it seems to fit in this case in good faith should apply.
Now you might wonder what these defensive expenditures are.
Basically,
these are costs that a person occur is to minimize damage to himself,
uh,
including the damage from making a mistake.
Judge Posner uses the examples of theft because of the thread of theft.
People often take out insurance and install security systems or get menacing
dogs.
All of these are defensive expenditures.
In the case of a contract,
if parties did not have to negotiate in good faith,
there would be a lot of investment in defensive expenditures to protect each
that each party would make to protect themselves against making an um,
uh,
a poorly thought out,
a agreement.
Defensive expenditures are bad because they are a waste of society's resources.
Removing the good faith requirement would induce more defensive expenditures
because people would need to investigate whether the other party is being honest
rather than taking their word for it.
It would require more defensive expenditures cause you'd have to make sure you
weren't a for getting a contractual term.
It would be better if people just negotiated honestly and openly and the use the
resources they would have spent on defensive expenditures.
Uh,
somewhere else.
In this case,
Posner characterized as the failure to disclose as sharp dealing a sharp sharp
dealing is when a party takes advantage of a clear oversight by the opposite
party.
There's no social benefit to inducing sharp dealings such as this one having
concluded that the failure to disclose the sharp dealing,
which itself might be a tort,
the balance of the opinion.
Next explicates the theory of post contractual cooperation in the performance of
the contract within which good faith operates to prevent opportunistic behavior,
deliberate advantage taking without justification.
The bottom line is that the less or on these facts should have disclosed the
contract clause much like a vendor should have a termite infestation.
However,
there's a limit to the good faith requirement.
Judge Posner does not think that every contract makes a party his brother's
keeper.
Otherwise Mirror difficulty of performance would excuse a contracting party
because the other failed to relax the terms of the contract.
There's another issue in this case.
Do you remember what the opinion said about whether the facts justify a summary
judgement ruling against market street for violating the duty of good faith?
The court held that no market street should not lose the summary Judgment motion
interpreting the facts most favorably to market street.
Because this is a motion for summary Judgment and market street is the non
moving party.
It would be possible to conclude that market street did not violate it's good
faith obligations,
so the case must be remanded.
So a,
that a jury can decide whether market street violated his duty,
uh,
by failing to disclose a for sharp dealing reasons.
In summary,
the decision in market street associates versus fry gave us a perspective on the
duty of good faith and contracting.
Good faith is an implied duty not to intentionally take advantage of the other
party's ignorance of the terms.
Somewhat surprisingly,
judge Posner fines that the law may require that a contract or a mind,
a sophisticated party of the terms of a contract that a sophisticated party has
already agreed to.
Posner explain that good faith requirements and the performance of a contract
help prevent opportunistic behavior and thus economize on inefficient defensive
expenditures.